this shit's binary either a good person
or a bad person even you got talent you
don't you're a good person you got
talent you win if you're the other part
you lost
[Music]
I'm in outlay making some [ __ ] happen
today headed to the airport
and a little bit and headed to Australia
and given for talks in three days and
being back in New York by Friday so
[ __ ] I'm grindin man [ __ ] working
out here dude I'm like a total
everything right now lot morning I don't
know you know what actually
dude please chop up like the three or
four highlights in here what's what on
my phone faster never the clouds running
totally different I'm positive there's
nothing like your phone working properly
I thought the ex was like a piece of
[ __ ] dude can you throw that photos
around but something got [ __ ] up with
my it my iCloud backup and like playing
with it right now come here to the last
24 hours is like we're 36 hours
incredible I just feel so happy yeah 10
minutes late for a meeting I hate that
feeling
[ __ ] hey Bevin you didn't pick a winner
for the
I went through some people but I didn't
find him
Blagh he just was witnessed a very
exciting moment for me
fab ins been getting the huge benefit of
you know the anti deer och propaganda
that I'm so passionate about but we've
just witnessed the first moment where
he's substantially dropped the ball and
came up with an excuse
Tyler's struggled with this at times but
he's been a lot better now he just owns
it but we just watched babban try to
come up with some horseshit excuse and
I'm enjoying this because it was a
really fun moment I hope he edits this
and shows the whole thing from where I
asked him I hope he recalls it I don't
know if he was filming yesterday when I
asked him to actually do it as some of
you know I did a caption contest to pick
a winner
I asked Batman because he had oh I don't
know ungodly amounts of down time
yesterday to help me scale the execution
he did not drop the ball solid fumble
when I asked him about it right now he
had a funny little face I wish I had a
camera on him thought for a second of
where he should go he went down the
excuse tunnel which is the tunnel for
users so we're gonna make this little
video right now this is gonna help a lot
of you and it's gonna help babban we're
not gonna let that fly we're gonna call
them out on it publicly to all of you
we're gonna move on our merry way and
you know it's been addressed him it's an
L it's a micro loss but how the macro
he's a great kid he's doing great work
and I have a funny feeling today and
we'll move on and next time he might
just you know Tyler I've watched now
I'll be like no that's on me at first
you'd like to do the excuses to Tyler
that's [ __ ] probably played with AJ a
little bit but you know we've now kind
of gotten you're good now at being like
that's my elf right and and maybe you
can occurred encourage Babin a little
bit later
well he still hasn't picked it up like
but we're forcing him into it right now
we'll see we'll see if he picks it up yo
it's a midday update
babban isn't done much but I am the
other hand has completely crushed a
bunch of Boehner sports meetings bunch
of client meetings for vaynermedia been
focuses [ __ ] nothing super glamorous no
keynotes no [ __ ] selfies on the
street just [ __ ] CEO life trying to
get it I left money on the table my
whole life Hollywood keeps calling said
of meeting with Jimmy I mean here's what
he had to say I'm sorry I have to do it
the only reason I'm doing this is
because I've made people do this with my
headphones I love it just one thing look
your [ __ ] legend - every single
[ __ ] kid watching this core belief of
what allows them to get to where they
want to be be willing to work harder
than the next guy take the next person
take more pain in the next person and
just don't stop [ __ ] and don't quit
that's it and if you're not doing that
you're gonna finish second or third
legend life yes of course then I saw
your blog be the wheel Rene nice to meet
you let's take a picture yeah
you're welcome nice to meet you bye my
solution take care have fun bye bye
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
big fan thank you thanks for the love so
lighting if the lighting is serious you
guys did it right like I know what my
comfortable comfort zone is and I'm
comfortable with that
but I also really understand why people
need to go their way and that's the
that's the [ __ ] thing man like don't
do it the way I'm doing it but just do
it your way and don't [ __ ] judge
other people's way see I feel like I'm
kind of a strange crossroads in my life
where I feel like because you know
you're about to explode
long long long thank you like heat like
I listen uh the man's about to explode
some are gonna be upset about it others
would be pumped cuz you've been there
from the get you're about to explode the
singular reason I'm here is because I
because I'm collecting people that
understand what the [ __ ] is going on and
the list is short you understand what's
happening that's it like I don't know
what to say that's the [ __ ] punchline
see a good night like that's the [ __ ]
thing so yeah you're an interesting
crossroads because you're about [ __ ]
15 seconds away from [ __ ] getting really
ridiculous and you're gonna be [ __ ]
crippled by options and you mr. long
over here gonna have to make some
decisions and the [ __ ] variables are
gonna [ __ ] him go in a hundred different
directions and you got some [ __ ]
decisions to make Thank You Debra
coolest podcast overall took us on
YouTube SoundCloud iTunes
Gary [ __ ] be check you off the
list
alright let's go Adam I really
appreciate it man thank you for the
hospitality that went well right it was
awesome thank you so much
put up our you know I'm good chimney
hell you basically I'm in caribou go
it's great nice to meet you
never thought I'd run into you I'm glad
we did man's leg while Connecticut I'm a
business owner
yes sir get it I look up to your i watch
all your songs I appreciate it brother
alright thank you so much oh thank you
brother thank you great meeting you
Thank You Man take care yourself yeah
see they go yeah like such a good part
of LA I don't want to leave I love this
street or not you know what well we
gotta go we gotta go yo guys looks like
babban is probably not gonna make this
flight which is gonna mean home for -
for my film crew to Australia there's
some sort of weird jinx on that we're
about to find out I don't think Bobby
gets on that's his nickname great day
huge huge huge execution in LA I'm happy
about that
see you later
[Music]